the most important point is give the
feeling to your team that they are part
of the team because if they don't i mean
you you find yourself in the battle when
you know you look back nobody is there
so
you know it's involve them in order to
get like involvement creates commitment
you know uh you should involve your team
so they can be committed feel very
identical to what you put as the goal of
of this uh battle now
you know otherwise they don't fight with
you welcome to 20 minute leaders just
sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact leap google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to a special episode
of 20 minute leaders this is exactly why
i love the show i i think that i'm going
to be entering some conversation and it
ends up taking a whole twist
without much further ado i'd like you to
meet yaniv cohen the operations manager
of twilio in israel
but this episode is goes much farther
beyond his work with twilio it's
actually about his own journey and his
perspective his optimism and i hope you
enjoy
[Music]
it's going to be awesome any of you are
the head of the twilio business unit in
israel but but your your journey spends
much more with over 25 years of
experience in in leadership roles in the
high-tech industry and in various
companies and and different domains as
well so i'm curious to sort of pick your
brain and unravel a little bit about
your journey your insights and and
what's been driving you all these years
so again thank you very much for joining
me and and tell me a little bit about
yourself
all right so uh first of all my name is
yanif cohen i was born in israel in
jerusalem
1972 which means i will celebrate 50 in
about a few weeks
so it's a good night
thank you thank you so much
um
actually back in time you know my uh i
would say that my substantial uh life
starts when i was 16 and a half
i had um
what uh what's called the lymphoma hot
skin infamous skin is a kind of a cancer
um
yeah in your lymphoma system in your
body
uh i was in the middle of my uh 11th
grade
and it you know it was just uh just uh
prognosed uh occasionally
and i had something like one and a half
very tough one and a half year of
chemotherapy and radiotherapy
so
being 18 you know in israel every boy
every girl you know go to the army
i was released from you from the army
because the rules in israel that if you
have certain uh diseases
you're not able to go to the army
so my parents and i'm really grateful
for what they did for me they pushed the
army very much to get me as a volunteer
so i was i was volunteering the army for
three years and after these these three
years i uh i was um
i was giving another three years so all
in all i was like six years six years in
the army
and
uh yeah and you know my first job in the
army was in the israeli intelligence i i
guess you know the 8 200 unit
yes yeah which okay okay great so uh you
know in my age uh in the last uh last uh
i mean the 19th
uh when when when i was there most of
the people were arabic speakers like me
i'm i'm a fluent arabic speaker so i was
a translator working very closely with
some very very interesting interesting
stuff then i was uh i i i went to a
training i became an officer
in the israeli army and then started my
journey for uh something like six years
just to summarize this part myself in my
life i think that's the most um
influencing
uh and that's the point i think that
this is that was uh impacting my life
but more than my life the way i behave
the way i look
at the world
the way i take proportions you know in
life uh
um so so that's my story back in time
when i when i was 16 i was getting
married when i was 23 i have by the way
five daughters uh wow
yeah we have two sets of twins
so uh wow it's a kind of a very yeah
very unique uh
feminine structure i would say
wait wait buddy take me back to to the
change of perspective this is a it's
interesting you know what
how how do you identify today looking
back that your perspective
has changed as a result of tackling this
disease what really changed in your sort
of neural structure yeah first of all
leave the day you know you never know
what happens tomorrow
honestly i mean you you really never
know in my case it was so uh so really
you know um it was a complete surprise
it sounds like yeah absolutely nothing
prepares you to that and uh the second
one is that um
you know nothing is uh is uh taking for
granted you know uh
we we see our lives you know when you
wait you wake up in the morning you you
live your life day-to-day job you know
you go uh you go here you go there but
nothing is so uh taking uh for granted
for me it was like a shock
and when i when i was fully recovered i
decided that i really want first to live
my life in a way like it's my my last
day every day
but moreover
i really want to give back to the
society give back to other people
that
need this kind of help consultancy
proportions in life
what life really means
so for me it completely changed my mind
in a way that i really want to give back
to people a bit of my experience a bit
of my optimism a bit of my
my personality and i'm a very optimistic
gun uh my colleagues know that um
the most optimistic guy they can ever
find smiling all the time even if you
know there are tough times everybody has
tough times right in his life trying to
stay very positive
and uh you know try to to uh stress it
out back in a very optimistic way so so
so that's who i am and and i think
that's the reason
just another one word that's the reason
i chose to go to work in sales
because i think
being a sales guy without being very
optimistic doesn't work
so
you need to believe to be a great
believer that you can send you can offer
you can be the best you can win because
at the end it's a it's a competition
it's a daily daily basis competition
that you you need to prove yourself and
to win and to sell
so that's where i found myself um
so a little before we get into the more
business side of things
you mentioned that a big part of your
meaning today and and the things that
you do is you know helping others
partially through optimism through
shared experience through your own
your own ability to empathize having
lived through such an experience
tell me a little bit about this
interaction with people that you may
work that you may be you know helping
that you're reflecting back on your own
experience
how is this translating to them what how
do you actually help them is it simply
just by being there and listening are
there different conversations that you
have with them
you know first of all people really like
to um
to find out some success stories so it's
very easy to get uh familiar
with people who who did something which
is very successful so treating this kind
of handling this kind of disease
uh when you fully recover people really
like to get uh get familiar with it
uh so i find out that people are really
curious to hear my story
uh
again
life is never easy
but having this kind of stories i think
give give a lot of hope to people and
you know i always say hope is not a
strategy hope is something that you
cannot
you cannot plan it you need to you need
to create it on daily basis so you
cannot just hope that everything will be
fine you need to make sure everything is
fine
and i think this disease that learned me
or taught me uh that you cannot just
count on lab
you need to be there every day and not
just hope but make make sure it happens
and i think it really it is really
it is really identical to what sales
mean you know being a sales guy
whatever level it is whether if you're a
sales guy or you know director sales dp
sales or a ceo
you always need to plan to be with two
legs on the ground be very practical
know what the plan is
and not hope but do so i'm a doer i'm
doing i'm trying to be very positive but
doing you know give the examples to
people around me
uh
so that's that's
if we're looking at sales and you're
experiencing sales you're mentioning
that optimism is is a huge part of it
how does that get translated tangibly to
conversations that you're having you
know obviously you want to be very
authentic and truthful about what the
product is but how how does optimism
play a factor in sort of the
decision-making process or the conver or
or the the way type of conversation that
you're having with potential clients
well um
you know we are in a very competitive
domain right i mean this is the high
tech iet projects id products uh the
competition is is very very tough
being pessimistic
never works right so you need to stress
out to your people and i have managed so
many people in my life
uh that uh we are the best
uh we need to to think how we should
stress out that we are the best
um
and you know this optimism sometimes
sticks to others you know because uh
when you're in the top like number one
your people need to be very aligned with
your personality they shouldn't be yes
man people but they need to be you know
in in full alignment of who you are and
and i'm trying to stick my people with
this optimism that it's it might be
might be hard might be difficult but we
never lose hope back to my disease you
should you should never lose hope you
should always you know hope for it and
make sure it happens so interesting that
that's how i make the
connection you know between my disease
the difficulties i had less of hope into
being a very successful guy going to the
army volunteering vegan officer in the
army i mean
never lose hope right you should take it
and do the best in order to to survive
in order to to be very successful
i mean i probably say sales that makes a
lot of sense because of the interaction
you're having and then optimism is
infectious but this is relevant for
anything in life right it's relevant for
any any type of position in any in any
job tell me a little bit about what
you're doing your day today as as head
of twilio's business unit in israel yeah
so twenty-o is uh a kind of a newcomer
to the israeli marketing it's only one
and a half year twilio as a company is
not uh you know is not a very old
company it's just a few years so
what uh what uh we are doing here we are
trying first to position ourselves you
know for for me
uh selling a kind of the product like
tweedio first of all you need to define
who you are but more important is who
you're not
because uh you need to find your
identity right in the markets for
instance are you going to the
small market are you going to the meal
market are you going to the top market
right you need to find out what's your
domain where is your playground that you
want to play you cannot be everywhere
right uh you need to find out so that's
that's the first one to to create like a
strategy
or creating something like that right
the second one is that we want to be
able to be the leading
product in the market
so by that we are organizing you know a
lot of uh
conferences
uh creating a lot of webinars creating a
lot of uh roundtables with customers
in in the domain we we decided to
position ourselves by the way we were
positioning ourselves to the high level
to the top enterprise market in israel
so
so first position ourselves create the
strategy
then you should be acting uh as a winner
uh understanding you know who are our
competitors what's the weaknesses you
know kind of a swot
analysis and then take it to the market
in order to be to be a leading one so
so
tell me a little bit about you know what
you know what really excites you
in the day to day so we we spoke
previously a little bit more generally
about you know sales and the way of
thinking and how you're bringing that
thinking mentality to
to sale to to your day-to-day job but
you know what what really about your
work whether it's with twilio or with
anything else in your career do you
really get excited about in the core of
it
um i would say uh
winning
i i can tell you that uh i'm 60 years
old after 25 years of experience winning
a project
uh makes me you know excited like uh
like a kid
and i think if you don't have this
enthusiasm
if it doesn't you know streaming your
blood
you're not aiming to be to be a
successful sales guy so what makes me
really excited is is winning
but winning based on strategy winning
based on process
winning based on things that you have
already created preliminary to the say
right in order to to to be the winner
because you know mike mikhail says his
life is like science
it is very very accurate it is very very
precise you need to you need to
understand exactly the domain you play
you need to understand your competitors
you need to understand everything in the
ecosystem
in order to be a winner you cannot just
win you know you do not say sorry she's
in the supermarket you're selling a very
top-level high enterprise rate solution
you have a few competitors if you do not
uh plan
you and execute at the best way you
never win in this kind of
some i'm talking
and that's what made me excited we we
just got yesterday uh appeal or an
announcement of winning uh the
municipality of tel aviv call center
it's gonna be yeah it's a it's a few
hundreds of agents in israel it's a very
yeah it's considered considered to be
one of the top projects here in 2022
and
that's makes me very very happy you know
more than the money
yeah you get excited by you're saying
you know there's this opportunity it's
not trivial you need to win it you need
to execute on it and and then you you
work tirelessly to create the strategy
and and that that winning mentality
that's sort of this game
that that that's what gets you excited
absolutely it's a chess game it's really
a challenge you need to plan your steps
in order to be the first uh on the right
mode you know that's the so
what else is there beyond you know
taking twilio's offerings taking the
requirements that the municipality says
and then you know figuring out if
there's a fit and then communicating
that fit how do you where is sort of the
chess
the the chess game that you're
describing here
you know first of all understanding what
your competitors offer and what's their
weaknesses you know there is a famous
sentence uh that i keep my lover close
and my enemies closer you know yeah yeah
so so you should keep your enemies
closer it means that you need to
understand their weaknesses their
strengths
the strengths and
strength of your uh competitors
so so it's by that i mean it's it's a
day-to-day working understanding what
exactly the customer what are the
demands from the customer
what you can provide what your customers
what your competitors can provide and
then create a kind of uh
it's like a
multi-dimensional you know year that you
need to to to make sure you can come
with the right price of course because
you you cannot be the the most expensive
sometimes you can but not in a big uh
let's say deviation from your competitor
so it's like a kind of a few dimensions
you need to play all the time
and make sure you have your management
commitment here in a month you have your
employees commitment to the project so
me as the one who leads let's say this
activity
uh mainly for a newcomer like twilio in
the israeli market which not everybody
is familiar with
this is a great challenge so so it's
it's it's like it's like a game you know
it's like a kid playing a game he needs
to be the best at the certain time
certain opportunity and make sure
everything works otherwise if something
drops you lose it
so
and it's so it's merely going and
certainly going from these different
projects and so you're you have
limited time per project and you know
that this is now where you're going in a
sprinting mode
all in on this and then you have a
little bit of time to recap and regroup
and then taking on the next project
absolutely and you know uh and it's part
of my personality all the time you
should cheer up your employees i mean
they you must make sure that they are
fully
happy satisfied
uh you know they're part of the team
they don't see you know like out of the
team but part of the team so you need to
take care about so many parameters
during this journey of winning winning a
project
and i think if we talk we talk now for
young young guys that listen listen to
us
i think
the most important point is give the
feeling to your team that they are part
of the team because if they don't
i mean you you find yourself in the
battle when you know you look back
nobody's there so
you know it's involve them in order to
get like involvement creates commitment
you know uh you should involve your team
so they can be committed see very
identical to what you put as the goal of
of this uh battle now
you know otherwise they don't fight with
you
and sometimes you find people you know
his internal politics fight against you
so everything needs to be so accurate so
so uh
you know precise in terms of what
happens on daily basis and and let's
let's not forget we have a lot of
opportunities so in each opportunity you
need to choose the best seller in your
team you know sometimes are you find out
that this one is is much better hunter
than than the others so sometimes you
put in here and there so you need to
manage it but you know that's what i
like
working with people
empowering people you know give them the
fee the feeling that they are part of
the team i think that that's at the end
of the day you know we celebrated just
we cheered up we we had a kind of a
whiskey
uh
a drink now on the team for this winning
in tel aviv the municipality you know
that's the end of the game
okay now we started another race of the
implementation but it's it's the end of
the game you call everybody to the room
you say well done guys you give him i
don't know you know like
a good uh
yeah it's up from here and and and you
know now everybody is full of energy to
go to the next uh to the next project so
you need to recharge the guys you know
like uh charging you know electricity
vehicles you you need to charge the dice
with the energy optimism guys we're the
winning
winning team and move forward so so
that's me i mean that's i think that's
what what i like on on my job so i think
it summarizes in a way
my history my disease my personality and
how i take it you know too
incredible
very very inspiring a winning mentality
very inspiring optimism and perception
um really really fantastic i i really
appreciate your time and your effort and
your energy yeah yeah so yeah thank you
very very much best of luck winning many
more games thank you so much thank you
for this opportunity
thank you so much and good luck to
everybody
cheers
you